expecting very shortly to see some
doctors walking out of the Manchester
Royal infirmary behind us and some of
their colleagues who aren't have who
haven't been on shift overnight to join
them in solidarity as well and we are
expecting a big turnout here in
Manchester particularly from this
Hospital trust a huge Hospital in the
city center of Manchester but of course
as you mentioned this will be happening
right across the country and a strike
which the NHS really has never seen
before and it's 75 years of existence
something that has just never come
across this organization ever before
four days worth of strike and the
disruption is expected to be Monumental
around 350 000 appointments expected to
be canceled including operations as well
so the strike starting at seven o'clock
this morning they'll run through till 7
A.M on Saturday today morning as well
and as you've been mentioning Kay this
is about two things that the doctors say
firstly they talk about pay which they
basically say the pay rise that's been
offered by the government isn't enough
and they are demanding more for that to
be in line with inflation uh the the
union voted overwhelmingly for these
strikes as well as a result of that
payoffer that was um produced by the
government but also the second thing
that doctors says for the last 15 years
patient care has been on the down and so
what they believe is that with increased
pay with better working conditions that
patient care within the National Health
Service can be a lot better but look the
disruption will be widespread NHS bosses
have said that over the next four days
the Health Service could be on a knife
edge and there will be people up and
down the country those who will need
operations who've had them booked in for
some time those who will need the
services of Junior doctors across the
country that will suffer as a result of
course the next four days will be
interesting to see how the National
Health Service plays out and whether
actually it will come to a point where
some of these Junior doctors who will be
striking this morning will have to go
back in to work